Kim Kardashian happy for XP Davidson as
he moves on to a new relationship
totally fine yep things are heating up
between Pete and Emily radakowski who
first sparked dating rumors earlier this
month
et's learning the skims founder is not
bothered by their budding romance a
source tells E.T Kim quote knows that
things were over between her and Pete
she just wants everyone to live their
best lives and be happy people don't see
the context behind it the source reveals
she's trying to focus on herself and her
kids happiness as she continues to
co-parent with Kanye you just gotta roll
with it last month E.T learned that Kim
and Pete have remained friendly since
their split quote Pete and Kim still
keep in touch it wasn't a bad Fallout or
breakup so things are good between them
and they've remained in contact Pete and
Kim started dating back in late 2021 and
after nine months the two went their
separate ways fans are getting a small
glimpse into the former couple's love
story on Kim's reality show Pete is has
got to be literally the best human being
I've ever like the best heart people
always say like oh he's so funny and
it's like has to do with how funny he is
that's like fourth on my list of why I
like him he even went over Kim's family
I love that he's kind and really really
thoughtful he's the most thoughtful
person and I love yeah and I love the
chemistry that Kim and him have together
it's really sweet I thought she said the
chemistry he's like okay chemistry
chemistry while the chemistry has come
to an end things between Pete and Emily
are just getting started earlier this
month The Source confirmed the pair's
relationship to E.T quote Pete and Emily
have known each other for a while
because they run in similar circles
they've always had a good time together
and liked each other I think
obviously women find him very attractive
yeah well obviously I mean he seems
super Charming he's vulnerable he's
lovely great his fingernail polish is
awesome like he looks good there you go
great and last week they were spotted
getting cozy hugging after a night out
for the comedian's 29th birthday
Emily is fresh off a breakup as well in
September she filed for divorce from
Sebastian bear mclart and spoke out
about the split last month quote I'm
newly single for basically the first
time in my life ever and I just feel
like I'm kind of enjoying the freedom of
not being super worried about how I'm
being perceived while Emily explores her
new romance with Pete looks like they've
got the stamp of approval from Kim
foreign